jour de la terre 22 avril 1990 new york
mutu switch on veut marquer les esprits
il réussit à convaincre les autorités de
fermer la 42e rue celles qui traversent
times square quitte à provoquer des
embouteillages dans les rues de
manhattan
certes le mouvement du jour de la terre
allait causer un pic de pollution mais
au moins rez-de-chaussée dit il cet
événement marquera suffisamment les
esprits pour être bénéfique sur le long
terme et donc et après vous à quel point
les rues de new york et elle encombre et
à la surprise générale aucunement au
contraire même la fermeture de la 42e
rue semblait avoir fluidifié la
circulation est comment est ce possible
comment est ce possible qu'en fermant
une rue la circulation puisse être
fluidifier et bien étrangement il s'agit
en fait là d'un cas où la théorie a
précédé l'observation
en effet dès 1968 le mathématicien
dietrich bref prédit que l'ouverture
d'une route pouvait ralentir la
circulation ou de façon équivalente sa
fermeture pouvait fluidifier la
circulation
c'est ce que l'on appelle le paradoxe de
bresse
c'est le vendredi soir nombreux sont
ceux qui vont faire le trajet du centre
ville à la plage il y a deux routes pour
ce faire chacune passant d'un côté de la
vallée
l'une passe par le musée les autres
passent par le supermarché la route du
centre ville au musée est une large
route qui contourne une montagne la
route du musée à la plage elle est une
étroite route de montagne
de l'autre côté la route du centre ville
au supermarché est une étroite route de
montagne tandis que celle du supermarché
à la plage est une large route qui
contourne les montagnes alors quelle est
la différence entre l'autoroute et la
route de montagne
il se trouve que quand il ya peu de
trafic les routes de montagne sont
tellement plus direct que les autoroutes
que le temps qu'il faut pour faire ce
trajet est très faible
le problème c'est que les routes de
montagne sont très étroites de sorte que
dès qu'il ya beaucoup de trafic
la route est immédiatement engorgé
d'embouteillages supposons pour
simplifier que le temps de trajet d'une
route de montagne est proportionnel au
nombre de voitures qui suivent ce trajet
al'inverse supposant que les autoroutes
sont tellement large qu'on ne trouve
jamais d'embouteillage sur ses
autoroutes
peu importe le nombre de voitures dessus
pour être précis supposons que le temps
de parcours des autoroutes est toujours
de 40 minutes alors que le temps de
parcours d'une route de montagne est en
nombre de minutes égal au nombre de
voitures dessus supposons maintenant que
40 voitures vont du centre ville à la
plage les deux parcours est en fait
similaire les voitures vont se partager
équitablement
de sorte que le temps de trajet sur
chaque route est de 40 minutes pour le
tronçon d'autoroute qui de 20 minutes
pour la partie route que montagne
autrement dit dans ce cas toutes les
voitures vont mettre une heure pour
aller du centre ville à la plage
ok jusque là ça fait beaucoup de blabla
pour pas grand chose de fou voyons
maintenant ce qu'il se passe quand on
rajoute une nouvelle route
la municipalité se rendant compte que
les visiteurs du musée se plaignent
régulièrement de l'absence de commerce
elle construit un magnifique pont qui
traverse la vallée
ce pont gigantesque qui relie le musée
au supermarché ne causent jamais aucun
embouteillage
le temps de parcours de ce pont est
aussi très très court en fait on peut le
considérer toujours négligeable dès lors
jusqu'à mi chemin
les voitures ont le choix entre passer
par l'autoroute ou par la route de mont
thain or tant qu'il y a moins de 40
voitures la route de montagne prend
toujours moins de 40 minutes pour être
parcourus du coup si chaque voiture veut
optimiser son trajet elle doit prendre
la route de montagne
ce qui fait que toutes les voitures ont
en fait désormais prendre le même chemin
en particulier elles vont tout mettre 40
minutes pour arriver à mi parcours est
de même dans la seconde partie du trajet
les voitures vont tout passer par la
route de montagne et met à nouveau 40
minutes pour atteindre la plage pour un
total d'une heure et vingt minutes et
c'est là que les choses deviennent tout
à coup étrange suite à la construction
de la nouvelle route les temps de trajet
de toutes les voitures sont passées
d'une heure à une heure vingt toutes les
voitures ont perdu 20 minutes passent
pas syrte que s'est il passé
comment est ce possible que le trafic
puisse être ralenti par l'ajout d'une
nouvelle route avant de répondre à cette
question remarquer qu'il est facile de
revenir à la situation précédente il
suffit de fermer l'accès à cette route
où il suffirait c'est plus dur d'imposer
à chaque voiture le trajet qu'elle devra
suivre comme par exemple forcer toutes
les voitures qui vont du centre ville à
la plage à rester du même côté de la
vallée
ok maîtresse at on pas la question
comment est ce possible que fermer une
route améliore la circulation après tout
une voûte de plus ça ne fait que
permettre plus de trajets possibles
non oui plus de route ne fait
qu'augmenter les possibilités de
minimiser les temps de parcours des
voitures mais le truc c'est que me
les temps de parcours des voitures n'est
pas l'objectif des conducteurs et oui
l'objectif de chaque conducteur c'est de
minimiser le temps de parcours de sa
voiture or comme vous commencez à le
comprendre je l'espère en général les
intérêts individuels ne coïncide pas
avec l'intérêt du groupe et le cas du
paradoxe de bras s est au fond un tel
exemple dans le paradoxe de bresse en
rajoutant et de nouvelles routes on
augmente les capacités des conducteurs à
nuire à l'intérêt du groupe
dans notre cas on leur permet d'aller du
centre ville à la plage en profitant des
deux routes de montagne à la fois quitte
à nuire à tous les autres conducteurs
présents sur ces routes de montagne et
c'est parce que tous les conducteurs
font cela que chaque conducteur est
fortement ralentie par les décisions des
autres conducteurs
et c'est là que réside le paradoxe de
bresse ok mais ce paradoxe de bryce est
quand même vachement théorique
en pratique ça n'arrive sans doute
jamais n'est-ce pas et bien en fait si
et ça arrive même souvent valiante
ehrhoff garden ont lancé des simulations
et montrer que ce paradoxe survient très
souvent surtout dans de grands réseaux
routiers et pour être encore plus proche
de la réalité
d'autres ont même montré que le cas de
la fermeture de la 42e de manhattan
n'est pas le seul d'autres villes
gagnerait elle aussi à faire mais
stratégiquement certaines de leurs rues
et d'ailleurs ce phénomène ne concerne
pas que la circulation routière après
tout on a des rambarde centrale dans les
métros pour fluidifier la circulation
des passagers
et on peut aussi trouver des
applications de tout cela dans les
communications à travers l'internet ou
encore dans les réseaux électriques pour
éviter la perte d'énergie par effet
joule dans tous ces cas interdire
certaines connexions peut être bénéfique
pour tous ok mais est ce qu'on peut
vraiment beaucoup il gagné à fermer des
routes alors la bonne nouvelle c'est que
le paradoxe de bref c'est un petit peu
le pire cas rappelons que dans ce cas on
est passé de 60 minutes à 80 minutes
en ouvrant une nouvelle route ou dit
autrement le fait que les conducteurs
elle
liberté de choisir leur trajet
proposition aucun on les force à rester
du même côté de la vallée a multiplié le
temps de parcours par quatre tiers ont
dit que quatre tiers est le prix de
l'anarchie dans notre exemple de
paradoxes de presse
alors petite note sémantiques je parle
ici d'anarchie mais le mot anarchie a
sans doute au moins autant de
définitions qui lie à d'anarchistes donc
s'il vous plaît ne vous excitez pas dans
les commentaire avec votre
interprétation de ce qu est l anarchie
ce n'est pas de l'énergie selon vous
donc je parle je parle ici d'une
certaine définition mathématiques très
restreinte qu'on appelle communément le
prix de l'anarchie c'est sans doute une
terminologie qui dérange beaucoup parmi
vous mais c'est une terminologie qui est
devenu standard en mathématiques
bref en 2001 tim roe garden et eva
tardos ont montré que quatre tiers était
en fait le pire cas où en fait plus
précisément ce qu'ils ont montré c'est
que katia et le pire prix de l'anarchie
possible dans les réseaux routiers
lorsque les temps de parcours des
différents tronçons sont des fonctions
affine du nombre de voitures dessus sauf
qu'en pratique il est concevable que les
temps de parcours évolué de façon non
linéaire typiquement une route peut être
parfaitement fluide à moins que tout à
coup un certain seuil de densité de
voitures est atteint auquel cas on a une
sorte de changement de phase et les
voitures se fige dans un embouteillage
atroce petit aparté rapide l'analogie
avec les fluides et si loin d'être
anodine de nos jours les meilleurs
modèles mathématiques pour étudier les
embouteillages sont inspirés de la
physique de la dynamique des fluides je
ferme la parenthèse
reprenons maintenant l'exemple du
paradoxe de presse
on va le généraliser maintenant à 40
purgation tels que sur chaque
intermédiaire on a une route de montagne
qui ce parcours quasi instantanément si
39 voitures l'apprennent mai mais une
minute poite parcouru s'il y en a 40 et
à chaque fois on a une déviation de la
route de montagne qui met deux minutes à
être parcourus plaçons-nous dans une
dictature ou un tyran éclairée et
bienveillante cherche à minimiser les
temps de parcours de ces sujets il peut
alors forcé la voiture 1 à prendre la
première déviation la voiture de après
la seconde et ainsi de suite dès lors
les routes de montagne ne sont jamais
engorgés et le temps de trajet total de
toute voiture est essentiellement le
temps de parcours de la déviation à
savoir deux minutes mais maintenant si
on se place dans une monarchie avec
liberté totale pour tous les citoyens
alors toutes les voitures ont toujours
vouloir suivre les routes de montagne et
toutes seront engorgées de sorte que
pour toute voiture le temps total de
trajet sera de 40 minutes en laissant
aux citoyens la liberté de circulation
on a multiplié par vingt leur temps
perdu dans les embouteillages et aussi
du coup la pollution émise ce jour là et
bien sûr le nombre 20 ici c'est pour
notre cas précis si on avait 60 millions
de voitures on pourrait trouver un
exemple similaire ou le temps passé sur
la route serait 30 millions de fois
pierre en anarchie que dans le cas de la
dictature bienveillante
autrement dit en termes mathématiques le
prix de l'anarchie n'a pas de bord il
peut être aussi grand que l'on veut là
on vient de revenir dans le monde de la
politique n'est mathématiques prouve
qu'il existe des cas où la liberté des
citoyens à un coût énorme pour tous les
citoyens en ces cas faut-il limiter les
libertés des citoyens pour leur
bien-être
alors bien sûr dans certains cas on
envie de dire que la réponse est
clairement oui par exemple on a sans
doute tous envie de limiter la liberté
des citoyens à tuer autrui est
typiquement avoir une justice qui punit
les meurtriers mais le cas du paradoxe
bresse est plus problématique en effet
supposant que les autorités ont fermé
l'accès au pont un conducteur qui
arrivait au supermarché via la route de
montagne voit que s'ils traversaient le
pont il arrivera très vite à la plage en
prenant l'autoroute de l'eau taille
en effet en supposant que le trafic
reste tel qu'il est ce conducteur
arrivera à la plage en 20 minutes
s'ils pouvaient accéder au pont sauf que
ces enflures tout politiciens
incompétents sont même pas capables
d'ouvrir se créant deux ponts vous
comprenez le problème mais sans doute
tous prêts à restreindre nos libertés
si on en comprend les conséquences
néfastes cependant en pratique dans de
nombreux cas il peut être globalement
bénéfique de restreindre nos libertés
mais il se peut aussi qu'il soit
incroyablement difficile de comprendre
pourquoi restreindre nos libertés se
fait pour le bien
de tous seriez vous prêt à accepter une
restriction de vos libertés sans qu'on
ne puisse vous expliquer en quoi cette
restriction se fait pour le bien de tous
et surtout seriez vous prêt à imposer
une restriction des libertés aux autres
sans pouvoir expliquer à ses autres
pourquoi cette restriction est critique
pour le bien de tous
j'avais enfin on a parlé du poker et
aussi de la solution au problème du
truel del vigie alors il semble qu'il en
ait plusieurs parmi vous qui ont pas est
trop aimé la solution que j'ai donné le
fait que j'ai pas assez parlé des
solutions que vous avez proposé
il y en a d'autres qui m'ont reproché
d'avoir posé un problème mal définie or
deux choses par rapport à ça la première
chose c'est que c'est pas un exercice
scolaire
je vous pose un problème comme ça damman
dans les défilés que j'avais pu vous
poser dans le passé chaque fois c'est
des problèmes qui sont pas bien définies
et ça ça contraste beaucoup avec les
mathématiques que vous faites à l'école
ou à chaque fois une réponse qu'on
attend de vous sauf qu'en pratique les
vrais mathématiques que ce soit des
mathématiques appliquées aux des
mathématiques pures
en général la quasi-totalité des
problèmes sont des problèmes mal posée
et tout le jeu notamment de la recherche
en mathématiques et tout ce qui fait en
fait pour moi l'intérêt des
mathématiques c'est de chercher à bien
formaliser les problèmes pour voir
quelles sont les questions qui sont
intéressantes à se poser donc ça ça veut
dire que si vous prenez un problème est
que vous reformuler le problème de façon
différente mais beaucoup plus
intéressant même si vous ne résolvez pas
le problème modifier le fait d'avoir
posé une question encore plus
intéressante que celle qui avait été
posée c'est ça c'est ça que j'attends de
vous malheureusement c'est vrai que
c'est un truc qu'on n'attend pas du tout
de vous à l'école parce qu'à l'école on
veut aussi pouvoir examiner les
étudiants et c'est plus facile
d'examiner les étudiants
quand on leur dit ce qu'on attend d'eux
et que
problème très cadré que ça c'est la
première chose par rapport à tous les
défis que je pose à gauche à droite
moi j'attends pas de réponse scolaire ce
que je veux avant tout c'est que vous
réfléchissiez que vous développez une
intuition de mathématiques que vous
trouviez des questions intéressantes à
vous poser que sa cathy votre
imagination c'est le but des vidéos
centrale c'est pas que vous puissiez
résoudre en examen que toute façon il
n'y aura pas d'examens
la deuxième chose c'est que au début de
la chaîne j'avais fait donc ses défilés
et c'était très cool à l'époque parce
que j'ai pas énormément d'abonnés du
coup j'avais pas énormément de
commentaires et du coup je pouvais lire
en détail tous les commentaires et même
construire sur les commentaires de
chacun pouvoir où chacune de vos idées
pouvaient amener malheureusement depuis
nombre d'abonnés augmenter le nombre de
commentaires augmenté et je peux plus
lire tous vos commentaires surtout quand
les commentaires font plus de dix lignes
ça me décourage rapidement je lis en
diagonale et dès qu'il ya un truc qui me
paraît mauvais bas je souhaite le
commentaire et je passe au dessus et ça
ça veut dire plusieurs choses la
première c'est qu'il faut pas que vous
attendez de moi que je lis tous vos
commentaires en détail je suis pas un
correcteur de copie est en fait la
raison pour laquelle j'ai arrêté les
défilés c'est précisément ça c'est parce
que je sentais que vous attendez de moi
que je lis tous vos commentaires en
détail
et si vous vous allez voir le dernier
défilé que j'avais posé qui est jamais
revenu parce que nombre de réponses est
tellement grand que je me sens le devoir
de la liga au moins une grosse partie de
toutes vos réponses avant de pouvoir
construire nos vidéos réponse et c'est
énormément de travail en de lire vos
pâtes et ça représente des pages et des
pages de
de lecture la lecture de ces pages et
des pages de commentaires qui m'a
découragée et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il
ya plus de défilés d'ailleurs je suis
pas le seul dans ce cas
dirty biology a lancé à un moment la
série l'expérience aidant le moba ça
fait trop de choses à lire et je pense
que c'est pour ça qu'il a arrêté et je
pense que pour l'intérêt de la plupart
d'entre vous il vaut beaucoup mieux que
je passe du temps à écrire dès la vidéo
principal est à - interagir peut être
avec vous mes affaires du contenu de
qualité plutôt que je passe le plus
clair de mon temps à lire des
commentaires qui peut être pas un
intérêt incroyable pour la plupart des
viewer que vous êtes en fait il ya un
troisième point par rapport au truel
belgique est vraiment spécifique de
toyal jc que le oprah mais en fait
beaucoup plus compliqué que ce que je
croyais pas quand j'ai posé le problème
je pensais pouvoir le résoudre très
facilement en faites vous si je l'ajouté
lire à vos commentaires et résoudre
prem's on a pris des heures et des
heures alors la partie réponse aux
commentaires des vidéos ça ne soit c'est
pas un truc sur lequel j'ai envie de
passer des heures c'est un truc son ca
être c'est rapide incertaine interactif
le gros du travail d'une vidéo sensor
aller le plus intéressant c'est ce sur
quoi j'ai envie de consacrer mon temps
c'est le gros de la vidéo pas la partie
réponse à un commentaire
bref je m'écris aussi la partie réponse
au commentaire de la vidéo précédente
vous a pas plu mais j'espère que vous
comprenez pourquoi j'étais dans
l'obligation de faire un truc un peu
torch est comme ça a été fait un vidéo
précédente
et pourquoi ce sera toujours un peu
torcher les réponses aux commentaires
parce que j'ai pas envie que ça soit le
coeur de la vidéo ivan indiana nous fait
remarquer que votre collègue j&j a un
nom en fait et c'est ce qu'on appelle de
l'impasse mexicaine est en effet j'avais
déjà entendu parler de ça mais j'avais
pas vu le lien avec les traits de lee j
donc merci pour ce commentaire c'est
super cool et un plusieurs baribeau
aussi qui ont vu que
lien avec des scènes de films notamment
dans le bon la brute et le truand vivent
les lignes fait remarquer que je n'ai
pas parlé de tout l'aspect psychologique
du poker et une raison très simple à
cela c'est que l'ibpt ratus cette
intelligence artificielle n'a pas de
tics nerveux ou n'a pas de problèmes
psychologiques et en fait la proche mais
très mathématique surtout de sefyu qui a
résolu le problème du poker de façon
très mathématique bien ça fait plus n'a
aucun problème psychologique
en fait que généralement le problème du
poker peut-être poser comme un problème
mathématique tous les aspects
psychologiques du poker sont des
limitations humaine me dire de la
commission humaines à la capacité à
développer une stratégie optimale au
poker mais le poker peut être définies
indépendamment du tout aspect
psychologique massive demain il nous
demande si libre a pu s'entraîner encore
encore et encore
est-ce qu'ils finiraient par résoudre le
peau claire alors il me semble que oui
survolé les articles de recherche il me
semble qu'en effet il a été construit
pour pouvoir calculer la stratégie
optimale du poker m6 il me semble qu'il
s'est adapté ses adversaires lors de son
duel contre les humains ceci étant dit
pour qu'il résolve vraiment le poker il
faudra bien plus que toute l'histoire
d'une unité et un disque dur bien plus
grand que la toute la taille de
l'univers donc en pratique nos rivières
et bras jamais comme un roc un peu déçu
que je ne parle pas plus de thomasz
synchrone qui est le chercheur qui est
derrière
libre à tous bon malheureusement il ya
beaucoup de chercheurs est difficile de
parler de tous les chercheurs autant
qu'ils ne mettraient chacun mais en
effet thomas salle rome est un très
grand chercheur en théorie des jeux j'ai
lu beaucoup de ces articles
puis pas mal moi même
ce mec notamment il ya deux ans j'avais
eu la chance d'assister à un de ses
séminaires où il parlait de cloud ico
qui était intelligence artificielle
avant libre à tout ce qu'ils avaient
perdu al contre les humains il faut
savoir que les travaux de thomas ça
tonne sont pas juste limité au poker est
en fait toutes ces théories ils sont
appelle la théorie des jeux bayésienne
qui est un truc sur lequel j'ai fait de
la recherche moi-même notamment sa part
est dans le titre de ma thèse notamment
la théorie de la conception des
mécanismes bayésiens c'est un domaine de
recherche auquel cndd rome a beaucoup
contribué et qui a énormément
d'applications en pratique et on les
verra de plus en plus dans les vidéos à
venir d'ailleurs athina ratsimba demande
une vidéo sur elinor ostrom et attraits
jdd bien commun bon là encore
heureusement j'avais pas prévu une vidéo
sur sept prix nobel d'économie parce que
il ya déjà trop de choses j'ai envie de
parler dans cette série sur la
démocratie
typiquement dans cette vidéo je vais
aussi parler de l'est ses variantes qui
est prix turing
c'est un petit peu le prix nobel pour
l'informatique et ce mec aussi une
mégastar que jacques myard bon voilà pas
trop le temps de parler de tout le monde
mais typiquement le prix de l'anarchie
c'est un concept qui est intimement liée
avec la tragédie et bien commun puisque
finalement on peut voir la fluidité des
routes comme étant un bien commun je
fait que tout le monde prenne la même
route gâche le bien commun or tout le
monde a intérêt à gâcher cette route du
coup on a une tragédie des biens communs
et plus généralement le pli de
l'anarchie c'est une quantification de
la tragédie des biens j'espère que vous
avez mais cette vidéo je vous conseille
très vivement d'aller lire l'article des
tennis sur le site images des maths du
cnrs sur le prix de l'énergie ou parle
beaucoup de choses dont je n'ai pas
parlé et je vous conseille aussi
vivement le chapitre écrit par emilie
neveu dans le bouquin la science à
contre-pied auquel j'ai aussi contribué
dedans et aussi un chapitre sur pourquoi
est ce que qui
faux la science à contre-pied est un
livre collaboratif du café des sciences
c'est à dire tous ces vieux réacteurs ou
va rencontrer sur le web temps des blogs
temps des podcasts ou sur youtube et
l'idée de ce bouquin c'est de présenter
des faits scientifiques surprenants
comme par exemple par tox de bresse
sinon pour les plus motivés d'entre vous
je vous conseille aussi vivement
l'article original de timour garden et
eva tarnos
si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à
de l'ikea le commentaire de partage et
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
invoquer futurs épisodes merci au team
apollo redon et j'espère que vous serez
là la prochaine fois
[Musique]